let's jump to this story from the
post-millennial breaking trans male
arrested for planning Colorado school
shooting had anti-trump Manifesto
Whitworth faces charges of attempted
murder after allegedly making threads
against schools in Colorado Springs
Colorado this is crazy so this is a
biological mail who is trans identified
his name is William Whitworth was
arrested and charged after police
investigation in Colorado Springs
revealed the 19 year old was responsible
for threats involving schools in
Colorado Springs Academy District 20.
the Eber County Sheriff's Office charged
with two counts of criminal attempt to
commit murder in the first degree
criminal mischief menacing and
interference with staff faculty or
students of educational institutions now
apparently I would say based on this
reporting this must have happened well
before the the mass shootings that we
saw in Nashville
however
when this individual in Nashville is
being called a victim by the Nashville
protesters by the national I'm sorry
insurrectionist to storm the capital
they held up seven fingers right
symbolizing that the individual who
committed the mastering was also a
victim
how many more people have leftist
persuasion will will think to themselves
if that if they do this they will also
be celebrated
well transgenderism the extremism it's
it relies on violence to get its way and
the era of violence when you tell
all your supporters and and folks going
through this like this young man that
critics of you or those who don't share
your views are
their their criticism is violence
genocide you know that that that it it
puts a Target on people's back that you
you don't agree with me that means
you're vile and if you're violent you
don't deserve protection and I can
defend myself against you if you're a
fascist you're outside the protection of
the law and we can go after you and be
violence This Is How They frame it they
frame it as though it is self-defense
right when you say words right so words
are violence you're all a Target America
you're all a Target
me not to see
a martyrdom component to this too like
if you feel like you are depressed and
you've got all these questions about who
you are and your gender and your online
community is telling you there there is
a need to take action now that in some
way you might find that you are uh
pursuing
you know basically immortality through a
terrible act and that you know for the
rest of us would deter you from doing
this but if you're in a psychologically
Disturbed State you see it as the
ultimate called action which is tragic
and it can it's terrible I imagine
imagine if you've been ripped away from
your biological reality but that's
what's happened to these folks
they've been caught up in this the
thrall of this extremism and everything
that people rely on to get through life
you know
I'm comfortable I it may I you know I am
what I am like True North yeah
everything everything and of course
that's the Communist way right they want
to take everything away from you so you
rely on them and their ideology
ultimately and that means tearing apart
the family the institutions that compete
with the state religion uh and also uh
tearing tearing you away from your
biology I mean that that would be the
best victory for the left well think
about nothing nothing is certain and the
only thing is certain is this
Consciousness that we were raised for
you through the Marxist Revolution I
think it's
it's poised to shift at any moment into
who knows what there's there's no reason
in my opinion that it stays with just
the gender issue because we've also seen
transracialism and things like this now
they've been slow to actually accept it
but it seems like they may be getting
towards accepting it because according
to their ideology they have no choice
but to accept it right the the argument
being that
if anyone can identify as whatever they
want
if a person appears white but agrees
with them ideal ideologically and claims
to be black then they must be they are
and so the door has been opened
completely to even transracialism now
you're starting to see universities and
that blows up our anti-discrimination
laws right yeah if you go in there and
you identify as a black owned business
who's to say you're not well Serge is
African-American that is correct I am
I understand but yeah and and uh you
know and that they kind of deny they're
rejecting all these fundamentals they
don't believe in Racial equality they
don't they believe in racial
discrimination they absolutely do not
believe in racial and I tell you and I
tell you this transgenderism the
targeting of children and the
endorsement of Mutilation of children I
mean that's demonic and uh uh if there's
a way to kind of denote something as
being good versus bad the this the
targeting of children in this way uh and
the endorsement of it by our political
class
you know well countries can't survive
let's destroying their children let's
put it let's put it uh simply in
Scandinavian countries they have stopped
gender affirmation as they call it for
minors they have stopped the the
countries the left claims are the
bastions uh the examples of good health
care have said hey this actually was not
helping yet for some reason and it's and
I think it's because the left is a cult
it doesn't matter what's true and
correct it doesn't matter what's logical
what matters is they gain power and the
cult says it's so so be it even if they
want to come out and say Sweden and
Denmark are so great okay well Sweden
and Denmark said stop doing this no they
won't well you know I'm convinced that
you can't an adult
for themselves or certainly for a minor
cannot give informed consent to these
this transgender trans you know
surgeries uh whatever you want to call
it and the fact that it's allowed both
legally or medically is a problem has to
be dealt with but no one should be no
one can do it under traditional medical
ethics no doctor can do it and it
shouldn't be allowed legally but they
adults and children because it's it's
like someone someone could you know
someone going into a doctor and saying I
want you to cut off both my arms that
should not be allowed to happen
and and the idea that someone can
ethically do that as a doctor or that
someone can consent to that on the
traditional standards of uh informed
consent walls and under and ethics it's
it's at odds with everything we know
about members but but see the question I
have with this when it comes to adults
is what is the ethical line and so I can
certainly understand removing someone's
arms because that makes them that makes
them dependent to a certain degree but
if someone goes in and says that they
want to be sterilized they can still use
their arms to eat sleep work and do
whatever I mean if a human adult wants
to split their tongue or get tattoos or
remove an earlobe or whatever it's kind
of like
uh people do a lot of weird body
modification stuff well what is the
treatment what is the treatment they're
seeking and what is it what is it
designed designed to solve but doctors
can't just do medical procedures that
don't work but but my my issue is the
the what is the line to which someone is
allowed to modify their body surgically
I don't know what the line is but I do I
mean just because I don't know what the
line is right now doesn't mean that it
ought to be legal to have you go in and
have a doctor mutilate
mutilate your body to treat your
transgender dysphoria that's that's the
opposite of what should be done
medically and it should be prohibited
under law just like other radical
surgeries would be prohibited in similar
circumstances what about tongue forking
well I don't know what the medical
treatment is what what's the consequence
of that happening and frankly it's not
something that doctors typically do is
it or is it something that it can be
done outside of a surgical I'm not
entirely sure there's also
um magnetic implants I tell you what
I'll let you do ton tongue forking if
you stop mutilating babies and children
and allowing adults to have their
private parts torn apart but we're not
talking about kids in this context well
I'm talking about adults having their
private parts torn apart but they're
choosing it I don't it doesn't matter no
one can ethic no one can Pro no one can
sensibly choose that I think you have to
talk about why right like if an adult
woman knows she doesn't want to have
kids and she wants to get sterilized
okay maybe she does have a reason to go
in and get a hysterectomy right but a
lot of the justification for the body
the genital mutilation or the general
modification done to adults or children
is we're preventing suicide and the idea
is that death is worse than potentially
you know living without an organ being
dependent on hormones anything like that
I think if you want to get your tongue
Fork because you know you want it and
it's not going to potentially completely
impair your life forever then that's a
very different thing than saying if you
don't let me get my tongue forked I will
die because you probably won't die sure
but that's that's an entirely different
argument I mean if someone went to it
but I'm saying like you can't I said
simply uh so I know people who have
gotten hysterectomies because they said
they just don't they want it done end of
story have a nice day I don't care and
then they've gotten the surgery and it's
like you're a 30 year old adult you've
made the choice for yourself you will
not have kids but you can still walk run
jump eat sleep work the only thing
that's happening is you can't reproduce
anymore it's kind of like
people get their tubes tied all the time
people you know get vasectomies the
question is what's the line now cutting
off someone's arms well now you're
creating an issue for society where
someone's going to be requiring
assistance and that is like okay that
that's that's that's where the line is
that I see I do think that there's a
problem with that I I just want to be
clear
no one can give informed consent
to gender mutilation surgery no one can
give informed consent so the law can't
allow you to do it doctors can't
lawfully or ethically do it and
certainly government shouldn't be
subsidizing it and promoting it with
children because well if you allow
adults to do it
to solve a medical problem right well
why well what if a child has a similar
quote medical problem the suicide the
suicide now now you know this is this is
this is another big issue so we now give
you whatever you want in terms of
medical treatment because you're so far
gone psychologically and emotionally you
could commit suicide otherwise that's
starting the night that's like a hostage
situation that's not medical treatment
they started to have to treat but I I
don't want to conflate
the claiming children can get sex
changes with a legal adult doing
whatever they want well they conflate it
so you need to understand I totally get
it and so I have I have a line there
where I'm like do I think people who are
adults should undergo body modification
at all no I think it's all bad but uh
okay if you're gonna if you're gonna go
you know get strange body modifications
because you want to look or feel a
certain way it's just kind of like
I don't know man that's just me I've
never been staunchly conservative in
that but going after kids is the line I
mean look at this still in Mulvaney
right everything he's about is the
targeting of children absolutely
everything he he when he talks about my
365 days as a girl what what adult
female
maybe I don't know what he's saying girl
he's already talking about Minor what
adult females go around talking about
girls in a regular way other than in a
joking way he is not joking and he and
he acts like a teenager he acts like a
young a young female act like a teenager
acts like a little girl well he doesn't
even act like any he doesn't act like a
caricature a caricature of what he
thinks a woman or a girl is but he's
targeting children thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time